all this fish didn't come from the ocean
it was grown in a lab
[Music]
cultivated Meats isn't fake meat like
plant-based protein it's real meat the
difference is that it's been grown from
cells in a lab and not in the actual
animal it's basically just what nature
does just growing the cells and we're
just giving them the ingredients to
actually grow in a healthy way this
isn't this stuff of Science Fiction
anymore the tech is now being used to
produce all kinds of seafood that could
help alleviate environmental issues like
the depletion of fish stocks health
issues linked to fish like microplastics
and mercury and also Animal Welfare
concerns but it's not yet in the
supermarket you don't know when it will
be available and the availability of it
in small amounts might come soon but the
availability in every supermarket in the
United States is quite a ways away still
the sector's growing funding for
cultivated Seafood companies hit 115
million dollars in 2021 while that's
still small compared with the 1.3
billion that went into cell-based meat
overall last year it's double the level
of funding cultivated Seafood received
in 2020 companies are producing
everything from fish fillets to eels
crab and lobster when I come across this
idea that we can actually make meet
without involving animals so a lot more
sustainable no animal cruelty as well as
a you know cleaner with less pollutants
in the product then that was okay I
couldn't find another reason not to
actually start working on this idea
a vault Meats has produced the world's
first cultivated fish mall or swim
bladder it's an Asian delicacy
traditionally eaten in soup we know Asia
consume over 60 percent of the world's
Seafood so we want to create a product
that will emotionally connect with the
consumer in this part of the world
over in Europe Blue Seafood is the first
company to produce market-ready
cultivated fish it plans to launch in
Singapore by the end of 2023.
there has been more than a decade of
work going into this from my co-founder
Sebastian and uh he has been developing
a couple of hundred cell lines from
prosthesis we do focus on three cell
lines a moment which is Atlantic salmon
it's childhood Park basically
um have yourselves to feed them with a
very nutritious drink and then the the
cells proliferate Singapore is the first
and only nation in the world that
currently allows the commercial sale of
cultivated meat it's not an easy road
ahead for the industry I would list
three main challenges for the cultivated
Seafood industry right off the bat the
first one is going to be the regulatory
approval in the U.S that means the FDA
we've been hearing that the approval for
these cultivated meat products is going
to come any day now for quite some time
we also are going to need to hear more
from the companies about the processes
used to make these products consumer
trust is a really important and major or
challenge that they will have to
overcome and third they are going to
need to provide really clear evidence
that this is better for the environment
that the energy that is necessary to
make these products is not more than is
used to raise or catch fish in the more
conventional methods
I think cultivated means technology will
be kind of like any other new technology
it will take some time for the general
config to accept it's kind of like the
electric car or a smartphone so is this
a future of seafood
probably part of the future but I don't
think that this is ever going to be the
majority of seafood or certainly not in
our lifetime
the way we created Meat and Fish until
now has been the way we did it for the
last thousands of years it is urgent to
to change that and I think we have the
tools to know how to change it and to
create a more sustainable way and I do
believe that this is the future of food
good
[Music]